how's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video this video is long
overdue but today we will be programming
an expert level Kinect for AI which is
going to be a lot of fun if you haven't
already I recommend you check out the
video that did before like a while ago
on I guess just programming the Kinect
for game and what we're gonna be doing
today is building off of that and
actually implementing the AI if you
don't want to like go through all the
effort of what like programming the game
from scratch you also can just go to my
github page and I'll link to this in the
description but there's a spot a Kinect
4py
so if you just click on the raw there
and just copy all of this ah this is
going to be the starting point from this
video I'll be programming in Python 3
and I'm using sublime text as my editor
so we should call this connect four
original dot py also if you haven't seen
it already I really recommend you watch
my video that I did called like how does
a board game AI work because basically
what we're gonna be doing in this video
is following along kind of the steps
that I go through in that video on the
theory behind a Kinect for AI so it
really will help you with the background
information on like how everything works
because it can be a little bit
complicated at times once you have the
file locally just make sure real quick
that it runs properly so when you run
this original file you should always it
not running you should get a screen that
pops up what it looks like connect floor
board and you just take turns being the
yellow and red player dropping pieces
I'll finish this up real quick and it
should do something like that when you
you win you don't have any errors to
start off so just make sure that
everything is working properly before we
actually get into the AI and with this
AI we're gonna start off just like I did
in the how does a board game AI video
work with the simplest approach we can
think of for the AI so we're just gonna
have it the player to just drop a piece
rain
somewhere on the screen so that's what
we're going to start out with
before we begin take a second to review
the code and make sure you kind of
understand how all the pieces fit
together because as we go through the
steps of the AI if you don't really
understand how the game is working it's
going to be kind of confusing the steps
that were implementing and to start off
where you are implementing the random
dropped he's AI so we run up and go down
to our game loop which is here and in
the initial game we were checking for
the mouse button down event and then
based on whose turn it was so turn
equals zero was the red piece I think
and then the else statement was player 2
and that was the yellow piece we are
making the jobs based off of that in
this random AI situation we are now not
going to have player to drop when a
mouse click happens is going to just
will have player to drop whenever right
after player 1 has made the move so once
player 1 makes the move that should
trigger player 2 to make the move and to
kind of make some of this clear I don't
like having like turn equals equals zero
popping up in the code all over the
place these are called magic numbers so
what I'm going to do real quick is just
to make things a little bit more clear
is I'm going to go up here and define a
static variable player which equals zero
and I'm going to have a static variable
or kind of just say yeah a variable
called a I equal to one and I will just
when I'm making these variables we'll
make it a little bit easier for me to
read the code and also as we implement
some of these functions with the AI
it'll make it a little bit easier for us
to understand how to implement it so now
attorney equals equals zero is turn
equals equals player and then for this
we don't want to end the let me make
this a little bit smaller just for a sec
over this makes you small make it bigger
but we don't want it to be in the if
statement if mouse button down anymore
we want it to be outside of this for
loop because shouldn't depend on event
should just depend on
when this I guess happens which we can
store separately so we're gonna move
this back a few okay so that now should
be in line with the for event and
instead of an else we can't have an else
without an if above it so what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna do if turn
equals equals AI and I guess we'll also
do and not game over because we don't
want this a piece to drop after the game
has sort of been finished
so if journey equals equals AI and not
game over then we have the random AI
making a decision and let's see there
might be some other changes you have to
make now that we did that one thing we
might want to do is throw the print
board somewhere differently actually
it's good right here
and let's see where else was I didn't
actually move it okay so I'm gonna move
this stuff outside of the loop to let's
see okay I'm thinking about this okay if
game over that should be in the loop the
turn what we're gonna do with the turns
now is only have them change when a
valley location was chosen so here the
turn is changing and same thing for the
player turn so if valid location then
we'll change the turn okay no not that
one less so inside the is valid location
okay so now what we what we have just
done we haven't really done don't worry
too much about the I guess logistics of
what we're doing but basically we're
setting it up so that we can pick a
random spot to drop a piece we're just
kind of having to do some I guess extra
work to clean up the code and set it up
for what we're trying to do
so if turn equals AI and not game over
cool and so now what we want to do is
that initially right here we this was
looking at where our mouse was and
picking the column based off of that
what we want to do instead is now to
just pick a random column so I'm going
to do column equals random brand int 0
which is the farthest to the left column
and we have column count columns right
but indexing is gonna put that off by 1
so we're gonna do a column count minus 1
and I'll pick a random number between 0
and I guess 6 inclusive to drop our
piece in and I have to I did not import
random so I have to do that real quick
all right I feel like I screwed
something up and maybe we'll get some
simple AI right here okay it seems to be
working but it's immediate and that's
kind of annoying but that's a good we're
doing well so far
oh and it's screwed up I just dropped a
piece in a winning location and it
screwed up there too so we have some
things we need to do so the first thing
I noticed that was really annoying was
right when we dropped our piece the AI
dropped their piece and that just
doesn't seem very like it's not a good
user experience so the first thing I'm
going we're gonna add is some time delay
for the AI piece so down here we have
the AI move and so basically what we're
gonna do is once this column has been
selected and is a valid location so if
it selects a column that's like not
valid I've already filled up or
something it will run the loop again
like nothing will have changed the turn
won't have changed or anything and it
will find a column that's valid and so
in the is valid location we're gonna add
a a delay so I really hope I ain't got
time to wait 500 and this is similar to
what we did
before when we ended the game just to
like hold the player 1 wins on the
screen so just like we did there so
we're gonna add that and so let's see
how it looks now quickly what the heck
ok so I noticed another issue so I think
it's working
but what's not happening is the board is
not getting re printed after the we
select our piece so the delay was there
but it was being weird because it wasn't
actually drawing the board again so what
we're gonna do here is once we select
like a is valid location we should
update the board because it will have
dropped a piece so I'm gonna add this
here see what looks like now yeah that
looks pretty good and it's moving around
ok it seems random but obviously as I
mentioned or as yeah as I mentioned in
the how does a board game AI work it's
when you just select a random column it
is such a stupid AI and it will not
block my obvious three in a row so I can
easily win right now also real quick
while I'm thinking about it I don't know
if you notice this but right now I
always get to go first so we probably
would want it to be random who gets to
go first it just makes it a little bit
more realistic and we'd want it to we
want the code to work if the AI goes
first so we can really easily add some
logic that will allow us to initially
initialize who goes first
and all I'm gonna do is turn equals
random R and int 0 1 or I guess we could
even do player AI which is gonna be 0 to
1 as well so what will happen now is
instead of turn where was turn
initialized somewhere in here
turn equals zero now turn is going to be
either 1 or 0 and the reason we can do
this just fine is because the only place
turn can change is after a valid pieces
have been dropped so basically what's
going to happen now is we're gonna enter
we're gonna skip over this event this
code right here on the first iteration
if we get 1 in that initialization step
and then the AI will drop a piece it
will switch to the player's turn and
then we'll start back up at the top of
the loop and we'll wait until the user
clicks and then run the code so let's
just see if that worked
oh yeah it looks like it worked
right one more time just to make sure
it's kind of weird that it's starting
yellow it's a little bit laggy or
something but it is working and I want
to just make sure that I can get a I
should be able to go first
at some point to okay yeah so after
three tries we initialized the zero and
I get to go first as before one more
thing before we move on to the slightly
more advanced AI is that when I was
running this one thing that I found that
was annoying is come on run Judith click
first is when the yellow piece is first
so you see how when the yellow piece is
first the yellow block popped up top
here it draws the yellow block up here I
really want that to happen now that only
we're always red so I'm going to change
this to turn equals player and then I'm
actually actually get rid of this
drawing the yellow circle on the mass
motion okay so let's see what happens
now yeah so now it just pops up
immediately and I could add another
delay but I'm fine with this cool yeah
all right let's move on to something
smarter and actually start implementing
the scoring heuristic for
so what we're going to be doing is
evaluating whether or not a board state
is good or bad based on you know how
many to and rows there are how many
three in a rose there are whether or not
you're playing in a center column and
you know vice versa for the opponent
having three in rose tuna Rose etc and
so this is exactly what we did in how
does a board game AI work video except
the one difference is that a lot of the
scores I think I was going through in
that video we're relative to the piece
you dropped so like you'd only look at
the three in a rose created or the tuna
Rose created from the specific piece you
dropped that turn what we're gonna have
to do when we're implementing that so
that we can use that minimax algorithm
is do that relative the score will be
not it will be independent from which
piece was just most recently dropped so
you'll kind of look at all of the board
and count how many three in a row is how
many tune rose etc let's define a
function called score position which
will give the will assign the score to
our board so I'm going to define this
right under the winning move function so
score position and if we're scoring
position we're gonna need to take in two
things in my opinion we're gonna have to
take in the board obviously we'll also
want to take in a piece so we have to
know whether it's red or yellow going
whether it's the player or the AI okay
cool and this is gonna be pretty similar
to how we did winning move or in a way
basically what we're going to check is
look at the whole entire board and
basically be counting the number of twos
in a row is three rows etc I think to
start off and make things easier let's
just count whether you win or whether
you win or lose so we'll just be looking
at for Neuros and we'll start off with
just horizontal so horizontal or score
horizontal I'll say
and let's say one thing I want to do
real quick just it's on my mind is peace
is defined as one or two so one is the
player this peace value and two is the
ai's peace value and that's another like
magic number so I'm going to just try to
like I'm gonna define two more variables
player piece and a eye piece player
piece equals one and this will just
apply my car code a little bit easier to
read again and a eye piece equals two so
let me just go through and try to switch
things out so this would be player piece
here this is a eye piece defined in
several locations godown player piece
right here drop piece this would be
player piece winning move this would be
player piece I think this one is
something different here let's see what
else we have down here would be a eye
piece and I think down here would also
be a eye piece I think that might have
been it not positive but just cleans up
the code a little bit okay so we want to
score the horizontal locations the way
that I think we should do this is
basically what we're going to do is we
could do it the exact same way we did
winning move but it gets kind of tough
with these if statements to count
whether or not like you have two in a
row exactly or three in a row exactly
because then you'd have to let you have
the factor in all the different ways you
can have three in a row so what we're
gonna do is I'll run the game real quick
no no what did I do
sorry just need to pass this function
real quick what we are gonna do instead
of that is basically imagine so look at
my mouse down here in the corner we're
gonna look at with horizontal starting
we're gonna look at window sizes of four
and just basically in those window sizes
of four
count how many empty squares and how
many filled in squares there are and
will basically be able to count then the
lines of two lines of three lines of
four from that so this is how it's going
to work so we have our board and that's
you know the matrix the row of rows and
columns so what we're gonna say is for
our in range row count so for each row
we're gonna want to do this and then
what we're gonna do is we are going to
define this row array and as row or a
the best way yeah row array so this is
gonna be all the pieces so if we're
looking at a single row this is just
going to be the seven tiles but just in
a single list so it's easier and we're
gonna define that as row array equals
int I for I and list board and then so
we want the specific row over on so it's
going to be board index of row but then
we want all the all the column positions
for that row so that's why we use this
colon right here you think that's what
we want let me just say and the entire
is just to make sure that we're always
getting something that's can be indexed
into the okay so what am I saying sorry
anti I think I just added this just to
be cautious that we didn't try to index
something with a float value or
something so that's our row array and so
then what we're gonna want to do is get
if this is like let's see we looked at
the board down here the row array would
be like this single list in here what
we're gonna do is look at all the pairs
of all the window sizes of four so to do
that we will do four see in range column
count minus three and the reason we do
minus three is because the last one
we're going to look at
is this so we don't look it look we
don't start with these last three as the
farthest to the left if that makes sense
I'm highlighting great in this area if
you missed that okay so we're getting
the horizontal windows and so the window
then will be a four will be the row
array and we're gonna index that from
our starting position so that's going to
be from C to C plus I guess four would
it be four or three I'm sure I think
let's do before yeah C plus four and we
can actually make this a variable too
just so you know where that four is
coming from I'm trying to call this
window length so window length equals
four so window lengths so we're getting
four at a time and then what we're gonna
want to do with that is count the number
of ones and two so AI pieces and you
know player pieces what not so what
we're gonna do with this window is
there's a built-in function of lists in
Python dot count so what I'm going to do
is count the piece that we're passing it
to the score position function and if
that equals equals four so that would be
we win so I guess if window dot count
piece equals equals four let's say we
have a score that we're defining so
score is zero initially will say score
plus equals like 100 right so if we ever
find four in a row on the board that's a
really good board obviously and so we
should try to get that move okay so we
have score plus equals 100 and then once
we're done we're just gonna do
horizontal for now and I'll fill in
we'll fill in the diagonal and vertical
later turn score okay so now we have
this score position function that
looks at a single-board state and gives
the score of a hundred if it is a
connect four and gives zero otherwise
and I guess for the sake of this that's
also preference three in our Ibis why
not
or maybe yeah three in row so if I'll
define this above I'll define it below
LF window dot count piece equals equals
three and window dot count of zero so we
should define this as a piece to so
empty equals zero this is just how we
are storing the values behind the scenes
window to account of empty equals equals
one then let's add I don't know ten to
our score so this is three and Rose this
is four and Rose right and then we
needed to find one more function and
that is just like pick best move and
that will give taking a board and what
else does this need to take in I'll
start with just the board potentially I
guess the piece too
yeah why not pick the best move so what
we're gonna do with this is we need to
look at all the different columns we can
make the move and then basically run the
score position on all those columns and
then pick the highest score that is
returned so we will write that as
follows so we have a function called I
think Valley locations if I'm not
mistaken okay no we don't but we can
define a function called it valid
locations real quick
so I'm going to do that def valid let's
just call it get valid locations so this
will show us which columns we can
actually drop it in and then
evaluate from there that is a board we
don't need actually have a piece to
figure out if it's a valid location or
not and so Valley locations is an empty
list to begin and for column in range
column count we don't have to do the
minus one here because this is exclusive
that that last value if is valid the
location of board and column then we
want to append that specific column
because that is a valid location this is
just getting us a list of where we can
drop this because we'll be doing a lot
this a lot so it's good abstract it into
a function valid locations dot append
column and then finally when we're done
we'll want to return the valid locations
okay so now we have valid occasions so
in our pick best move we'll need to use
this so valid locations equals get valid
locations of the board and let's think
what else we need to do so what we're
gonna want to do is four column in valid
locations we want to figure out what the
row is basically what we're gonna do is
to make our life easier is we're going
to pretty much simulate dropping a piece
and then have this new board that
actually gets passed into the score
position because we actually just taken
a board object there so we have to kind
of simulate each move to actually
evaluate using that function so we're
going to do is use our function get next
open row and that takes in the board and
the column and then this is something
that's tricky and non-intuitive is we
can't just drop the piece into our
current board and array we can't even do
something like this we can't say like
temp board equals board and then say
okay let's drop drop piece in the temp
word
row-column and I guess peace we can't
use this temp board to simulate the drop
piece because what actually happens with
the numpy objects that we're using to
store all the values is that this temp
board ends up pointing to the same exact
memory location as the original board so
what we actually need to do is make a
copy of this board so this is creating a
new memory location where our board is
sitting and what we're doing is passing
that new memory location into our drop
piece function so any modifications
don't modify our original board
hopefully that made sense let's draw a
piece and then we want to basically find
the score of the new board so guess what
happens is this drop piece automatically
modifies temp board so we can just go
ahead and do score equals score position
of the temp board and whatever a piece
that we dropped and then what we'll want
to do is basically keep track of a best
score so we'll say best score and we'll
set that to zero initially and we'll
have best column and that'll just be
like we'll just put it as a random
choice of the valid locations and I
defined about applications below this so
I'm gonna just move these I remove that
down here okay
so we have our best score and our best
calm best score is initially zero best
calm is just random but what we can do
is if this score that we scored with
this new board is greater than if score
is greater than best score
then we can set our new best score to
score and we can set the new best column
to whatever column we were checking when
we got this new score okay does that
make sense and then finally once we do
this we'll do return that's call think
that it looks right all right let's try
that out real quick so all we should see
here is we didn't add that anything too
complex we just made it preference
winning horizontally and getting three
in rows horizontally so we shouldn't be
looking at any sort of vertical maneuver
okay so instead of the random location
here I'm going to comment this out and
do column equals pick best move of the
board and I guess we're the AI here so I
need to pass in the AI piece come on
moment of truth I'm going to stack on
top of okay so now we should see it
connect three in a row that's what we're
hoping for and it did it cool so I'm
going to just stack a top again the way
we scored it too it should now
preference feeling this in after I drop
which it did whoo we got something a
little bit smarter okay now that we have
the score working for the horizontal
moves we can kind of expand upon this
and make it work for diagonal and
vertical as well I also do a little play
a little bit of cleaning so it yeah
we're where's the code okay pick us move
struggling it okay yeah so this is
horizontal so we need to also do
vertical vertical is also easy so score
vertical
next so that before column and range
column count the ones that are tricky
are the diagonals so we're doing the
exact same thing we did with horizontal
but we're gonna do it with vertical and
then once we have it for each one will
actually probably improve how we're
actually scoring this make it more like
I did and we did in the other video
right for C and range column count let's
see what else we should do we should
then get the column array right which is
going to be similar to the last time
it's gonna be int I for I in list so
this time we have the we want to get
every row position for a specific column
so we can do it like this I believe I
think that's what we want and then we'll
want to iterate through the windows just
like we did last time but now we have to
iterate through the row window so for R
and range row count minus three window
equals row array C or R to R plus window
length and we can copy this once wait
now that we have the window this code is
oh she didn't want to delete it this
could is the exact same so I can just
add this code and what we're gonna altum
Utley do is abstract away this window
counting stuff to its own function so
okay so now it should if we run this
again it should preference vertical as
well so I'm gonna block the horizontal
and it's still stupid and it's oh it
actually did block me that's interesting
but I'm gonna let it get okay so now
that it has two verticals in a row it
should preference making the move right
on top of it next if we did this right
and it didn't so I'm guessing we did
something screwy
it's weird hmm this is weird
maybe it's just getting lucky okay it
should hopefully win vertically let's
see I don't know we did something wrong
window count piece score plus equals
hundred what did I do wrong here oh
shoot I grabbed row array this needs to
now be column array okay sorry about
that
and also for our Ranger okay yeah okay
that should be good hopefully let's see
if it preferences vertical move is now -
so I'm blocking the horizontal and now
basically once it stacks I'll shoot I'm
gonna block the horizontal again but
come on okay let me play it again so you
can see exactly what I was trying to
show you right so it goes I'm gonna
block the horizontal and hopefully it
stacks on top
okay now that it's stacked on top we
should because it doesn't have any sort
of horizontal options it should stack
again and it does and so it now should
win vertically okay cool so with that we
kind of mainly validated that it was
getting these windows correctly for the
vertical okay so this was getting if we
think about this same graph it was
looking at like the sliver if we just
cut off this one column it it was making
a list out of these sorry these numbers
zero zero two two two two okay now let's
do diagonals diagonals are a little bit
weird so we'll start with the positively
sloped diagonals so the ones that are
low on the left side and rise up to the
right side so score positive sloped
diagonal
all right so let's just run the game
real quick just to see that how we're
gonna do this so basically if you look
at my mouse we're gonna look at all the
possible ways we can do this diagonal
slope so we can do like this I can move
over do this move or do this who over do
this and then rise up one row and do the
same thing so basically now we have to
go from like row count minus three as
well as column count minus three and do
a little bit of manipulating like that
and it's a little bit weird to get our
windows but it shouldn't be too too bad
so let's start with this so we're gonna
iterate starting with the rows so for a
row our end range row count minus three
because we're gonna be cut off at the
top because we're going up each time
once and then for C and range column
count count minus 3 because we can't
just have a okay so and that's because
we're going to the right each time for
so we have to cut off early for that as
well and then what we need to do is our
window is going to now be we're going to
do a little list comprehension to do
this it's going to be the board at the
row position and then at the column
position and what we're gonna have to do
is we're gonna have to add a little bit
of value each time so it should start
with 0 so we're atha we're gonna just
add some I plus I and that's gonna be
for I in range window length so
basically what's happening is if you
think about what I takes on if window
length is 4 I is going to start out at
zero so that's going to be just the
earth the position at are come a seat
then we're going to this is going to
become one so we're going to increase
positively one and one so we're gonna go
up and then across and that will
continue and we'll actually get our
window in the proper we'll get will get
us window size of four that is a
diagonal and this will repeat this
window right here will repeat for all of
these values so we'll end up getting all
of the positively sloped diagonals and
so we're gonna just be and just copy
this code here and we can do the same
for negatively sloped diagonal so for R
and range will do the exact same thing
oh my gosh stop texting me
ah sorry 4c and range column cap minus
three and this is a little bit trickier
because now we need to stop start at the
top and go downwards so to do that bear
with me
we're gonna want our window to be equal
to do list comprehension again board R
so this is going to be the same exact as
before but now oh my gosh this is
annoying
Wow
I'm never what is this crap sorry I'm
gonna turn off the volume there we go
okay so what I was saying was now the
first thing we check is up here so
that's going to be the row plus one plus
two plus three to get that position so
that's gonna be Rho plus three and then
the C I think will stay the same no
we're going to be going downward so
that's going to be C plus three as well
to get the position we're looking for
because we're going downwards just C
plus three
do we want C plus three yeah that should
work
sorry I'm just confusing myself now I
guess the C stays the same
so C is normal and Rho plus three and
then we'll - I and we will in this case
we will plus I for I in range window
length think that should work let's
think so if we think about all the
different combinations start with this
position that's the seer the 0th column
that's good then we go down one the row
decrease but the column increased down
again row increase with the column
decreased down again row increase or Rho
decreases but column increases so I
think what we did here is good and we
can score that just like we scored the
other ones so a little bit tougher to
test so what we'll do to test these is
will temporarily comment out the
horizontal and vertical and just see if
it when it has the option and sees the
day I know that it preferences it so
I'll make it easier for it
so if it puts it here here we should see
on the next time it putting a three in
the row okay yep it did I made them
moves a little bit quick but as we can
continue basically oh shoot
don't make that if I put it right here
it should if we implemented these
diagonals properly connect it yay we can
go ahead and uncomment all of this now
that we've checked that diagonal I guess
we should ideally check positively
sloped too but I'm pretty sure we're
good there okay and now what I recommend
we do is we're gonna want to add a
couple more different ways we can score
this and just so we don't copy all this
into each one of these individually
let's abstract out a new function called
like I don't know find it called wind a
value a twin died about evaluate window
and we'll take in the board and the
piece that earlier I guess not the board
we just need the window and I guess the
piece for that so this is going to be
the exact same thing as we did before so
if window dot count piece equals equals
four score plus equals 100 LF window dot
count piece equals equals three and
window cut count is empty equals equals
one score plus C equals 10 let's think
what else we should have should also
have an LF for window dot count piece
equals equals two I guess but it doesn't
really matter if we use it for hell if I
don't think here and window dot count
empty actually it does I know it doesn't
I don't think it does
empty equals equals to the do score plus
equals five and these values these are
kind of arbitrary and I'm fine leaving
them as kind of arbitrary eyes I really
need to extract these out into their own
variable so I guess
I could if I wanted to but basically
these are the type of values you play
around with as you kind of tune and try
to make your AI better let's see what
else we could do it could also have like
I guess in verse piece so this would be
the opponent piece so I can just call it
opponent piece equals we'll just say
player piece point of peace equals
player piece and if piece equals equals
player piece then we're just need to
switch it so that would be then opponent
piece would be equal to AI piece if that
made sense what I did I just was saying
that okay let's assume where the AI and
set the opponent piece to be player
piece but if we're not the AI and where
the player and where I've added in the
window then the opponent piece should be
AI piece so we could also do is
something like if window dot count
opponent piece equals equals three and
window count dot opponent or a window
count empty equals goes one and then
that means the opponent has a three in a
row and we could do like score minus
equals eight let's say so it's like we
weigh us getting a three in a row more
than we weigh the opponent getting a
three in a row okay just to finish up
this function we should initialize score
equals zero and it will return score at
the end and this is just gonna be so
then when we actually go into the score
position you can delete these lines and
what we'll actually do is do score plus
equals evaluate window of window piece
and we just copy this line here for each
of the other locations that we added
these logic cool cool
cool all right let's see what happens
auto plus equals none type oh yeah she
better turn the score okay so we should
be seeing some preference so it should
probably want to get this three in a row
yep okay
will it block me so it doesn't seem to
be blocking me let's see if it
preferences diagonal downwards
I guess it's diagonal that way let's see
if it preferences diagonal downwards now
cool it's looking pretty good
however it's not blocking me so that is
an issue so it's not blocking me and the
reason it's not blocking me I just
realized is if we look at this if we
think about how this evaluate window is
working we're only calling it for the AI
so if the AI ever sees the opponent has
three and the window count is one empty
is one then the opponent already has
three so would be able to win in the
next case so in this case it would be
preferencing putting three in a row over
blocking the opponent so watch what
happens if I make this like negative
eighty now it's going to preference and
I also will have to will have to change
the best score to be some sort of low
negative number to start just so it
doesn't screw up if we get a negative
here now it should block always block if
I ever get three in a row yeah see that
cool I don't know if we'll keep this in
when we go to minimax and we're gonna go
to min max rater around right really
soon the last thing I want to add before
we go to implementing the min max
algorithm is just scoring the center
columns and and you know adding
preference for center pieces because
that's what's going to create more
opportunities with the diagonals and
horizontals is if you have the center
center pieces okay so we can get our
Center array so score Center and I guess
this should be I'm going to move this
comment right below the score equals
zero move this up a bit and now I'm
going to add the score center column so
we're gonna create a center array just
like we were kind of making the row or
the
Calma raised within the score vertical
so we're going to do equals int i for i
and lists we want the board and we want
every row position but we only want the
center column so we can do column count
and then we could just you know may and
i think about it 0 1 2 3 would be the
middle but just to kind of not have
magic numbers i'm going to do floor
division by two so that will get the the
middle column and then what we want to
do is just do center count i guess
equals center array dot count piece and
then we'll just add to our score I don't
know three points or so yeah I'm kind of
did some weird numbers here I would had
like six for each piece in the center so
Center her score plus equals six let's
say and these numbers are all going to
change so don't worry too much about all
the score increases this is something
you play around with okay let's see if
it's preferencing Center now it should
not have gone there for this
preferencing Center four plus two equals
six
let's really crank up this score real
quick and see if it works it's weird
yes something is goofing
oh okay sorry housing plus equals six
but I was it should be plus equals
center count times six right so if you
had to it'd be 12 plus 12 it would be if
you had three would be plus 18 etc okay
now it looks like it's preferencing
Center we'll see
should block okay cool
no I think it should go Center if I'm
not mistaken yep cool and probably
should go center again if I'm not
mistaken okay I guess that creating more
diagonals but okay Center cool should
block and go Center cool think that's
accounting for the center alright with
that I think we're ready to move on to
the min/max
algorithm and what I think is helpful at
least when I was implementing this is I
went ahead and just was reviewing the
Wikipedia page on minimax so you know if
you didn't watch through the video I
posted minimax is basically a way so
that we can look down the branches of
any sort of rule based game like chess
checkers and in our case connect 4 so we
can basically look down at branches and
evaluate using our score function the
best branch that we can guarantee
getting so what I recommend we do is go
ahead and go to the pseudo code and this
is all we really have to implement so
function minimax node depth maximizing
player so the node in our case is going
to be the board depth is how far we want
to search down in our game and
maximizing player is going to be true
for the AI and false when we're looking
at the players move so let's go ahead
and implement this and I'll be kind of
popping this window back in and out okay
so if score position is good let's
define mini max
okay deaf mini max so we're going to
pass in the board we're going to pass in
the depth I'm going to pass in the
maximizing player and then we're gonna
do pass for now okay what do we need to
do next in this if the eps depth equals
zero or note is a terminal node so what
does the terminal node in our case well
that's whenever a game is one or I guess
we get to the end of the game those
would be terminal node conditions so
then we want to return the heuristic
value of that node and else we want to
kind of recursively check our tree like
you see in this diagram down the bottom
right and find the best score so that's
what's happening down here let's start
out though with the I guess if depths
equals zero condition that's when we're
going to be returning the score position
function score okay so what are okay so
let's do this if depth equals equals
zero or terminal node so this terminal
node we haven't defined yet so let's
just define it so what we just said was
turtle nodes would be us winning the
opponent winning or you know you've used
all the pieces in the game so let's do
those so I'm going to find another
function sorry is terminal note and now
we'll just be true if it is a terminal
node and false if it is not now that
taken aboard so what are the terminal
node conditions well we have this
winning move function right here so
basically we can use this to our
advantage so if it's a win if this
returns true for either of the pieces
then it would be a terminal node so
those will be to our conditions so we
want to return winning move board player
piece
or winning move board AI piece or the
final condition is that there's no more
valid moves in the game so the board is
completely filled up so we can do in
this is we can say length get valid
locations of the board and that length
should be zero if it's a terminal node
so this statement has is will return
true if it is a terminal node and false
otherwise
it's nice one-liner so what we're now
gonna do is I guess valid locations
equals get valid locations of the board
and then we're going to do is terminal
will be equal to is terminal node of the
board so now we can do if depth equals
zero or term of note or I guess or is
terminal okay what do we want to do in
this case well there's three conditions
so if we are the AI then the first thing
we want to do is we want to if it is a
winning move for us the AI we want to do
if winning move so this is basically
just figuring out which case of these
three we're in if winning move board AI
piece then we want to return a high
score so return like you know a really
big number
LF winning move board player we want to
return a really player piece sorry we
want to return a very low score
and we're going to augment this so it
also has a position but you'll see that
in a sec okay turn a really low score if
it's losing condition and then else this
is going to be when we evaluate our
score position this is a board that is
not a winning condition so and it's not
a terminal condition so we actually want
to get the score for it so we're gonna
do and I'm really just following if
you're getting confused with what I'm
doing I'm doing this step of the minimax
algorithm and I'm just finding the
heuristic value of the node and these
are kind of two edge cases the winning
move cases and I'm just handling them
separately I guess they could be kind of
factored into my minimax but just
because you know we're only really
looking at the opponents it might work
if I didn't handle these separately I
just in my head it makes it easier if I
handle these separately then finally the
else condition is when we want to
I guess the else condition here would be
the game is over so that's just kind of
like a weird case where we had returned
zero I suppose because you can't really
do anything from there alright cool so
we have the that's part of it
and now the final thing is if it is not
no I'm sorry if is terminal that's the
is terminal cases either we win the
opponent wins or the game is over those
are the three cases so I can just even
mark this game is over
comma no more valid moves the other
cases the depth is zero so you can just
do else here and that's gonna be depth
is zero and in that case we want to find
the heuristic value of the board so what
we're gonna do is just do return score
since score position of the board and I
guess whatever piece we dropped so in
our case it would be the AIS piece I
guess maybe it would be good to specify
this but I'm just going to keep it as
the AI piece right now you can fix it if
you need to all right so that's the
first part of the minimax and sorry if
this I hopefully this is not too
confusing it'll all kind of fit together
once we you know get through the rest of
it alright let's finish implementing the
minimax so let's do the bottom half of
that what I was just highlighting on the
Wikipedia page and also this should be a
piece the AI and the player without the
pieces just only was used for the turn
okay all right so else yeah let's see
what does that say if maximizing player
then and we returned out of this so this
week if you get into this if statement
you'll not get into the other ones that
we're about to define so if maximizing
player and I'm gonna just actually I
think will be easiest as if I just keep
this on the screen
whereas the pseudocode pseudocode okay
cool so we have the pseudocode on the
screen and we have the code over here so
gosh now let's make this the other half
okay not too bad alright so if
maximizing player I'm following right
here so my using player then we want to
initialize the score to some really low
value so we could do here is I think we
actually use if we actually want to
specify a negative infinity and positive
infinity I think what you can do instead
is we can do value equals math dot
infinity that works and I can actually
just do negative math dot infinity okay
so that covers that and then for each
child of notes that's for each position
we can drop in our connect for game so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to do four column invalid
locations which I already have to find
up here fortunately for us call an
invalid locations comma row equals get
next open row of the board and that
specific column that we're looking at
and then as before when you're just
doing this the score position function
we need to copy the board so board copy
just because otherwise we'll use the
exact same memory location that the
board is on so it will really screw up
when we're you know we're cursive Lea
doing this okay and we can go ahead and
drop a piece in that position be copy
row column and we are the if we're
maximizing player then where the AI
piece alright and so what's going to
happen here is we're gonna have a new
score
score which is going to be equal to the
minimax
which is going to be the max so if you
look at this it's going to be the max of
the current value which is negative math
infinity and minimax of depth minus one
so new score I guess would just be the
max of current square which was value
and minimax
of this is our recursive call here of
the board copy depth minus one and I
guess we do false now because we're no
longer the maximizing player right now
that minimizing pire cool and then
finally what we want to do is return the
new score so that's the back to the
value and the minimax and we want to do
the same thing for the minimizing player
so else we know we are the minimizing
player and that is the code right here
we want to initialize a value to
positive infinity and now copy the same
thing for column invalid locations same
as for row equals getint next open row
of board and column we only need to copy
the board again because we don't want to
use that same memory location otherwise
might have issues when we try to recurse
back up the tree drop piece equals o
board copy row column and now we are
going to be the minimizing player so
what we need to do is actually make this
piece the player piece and same for the
new score though is going to be because
when we are if we remember
this the minimizing players trying to
take the lowest value so if you see this
node right here this 10 10 and plus
infinity 10 is the lower node so it
always take that so in the minimizing
player case we want to take be the new
score would be the min of the value and
minimax of word copy depth minus 1 and
then we want to do true for now
switching to the maximizing player so
this this false and this true is what's
allowing us to switch back and forth
between this maximizing player and the
minimizing player in the context of the
minimax algorithm and make sure you
understand the minimax algorithm watch
the video that I've posted previously on
it or just kind of review this Wikipedia
page to kind of get a feel for how it
works because that is crucially
important for understanding how this new
AI is working okay and we want to return
value or the new score cool I think this
is about it right think so however the
one issue I have right now as I look at
this is we're returning the score which
is good to know like how good of a move
can we make at a certain location but we
also need to augment the score with the
column that produces that score so in
addition to just producing or just
figuring out what the best score is we
need to figure out which column produces
that score so to do that we're gonna
just actually get rid of this Max and
min we're gonna just break it out a bit
just it's easier to keep track of what
we need so we're gonna say that the new
score is equal to the minimax with that
same thing for this and instead of doing
it in just one line we're going to just
bring it to the new line so if
new score is greater than the value
value equals new your score so this is
the same thing right now if we kept it
like this this is the same thing as the
max the one liner we just had but we
also want to do something like column so
this this column right here is like the
best column you can get so we could
initialize this to just a random choice
of the valid locations random dot choice
valid locations and same thing for down
here
column equals random choice of the valid
applications right so now what we have
is column equals whatever column we are
currently iterating on that gave us this
new score when we recursively did the
minimax algorithm so that would be call
and okay that looks I think this is good
here we also no need to now implement it
down here same thing so this time of the
if new score is less than the value we
want to do value equals new score and
column equals call and we want to okay
and then finally what we have to do is
instead of just returning the score we
want to return both the score and the
column that produces that score so we'll
return a tuple so do column and new
score I guess if value is our final
thing that we returned same thing here
turn column and value and then up here
these are the terminal conditions so if
we get a terminal
we don't actually know which column
produces the terminal location because
it's just looking at the board
particular but we can get that very
easily because we would get through this
so basically what we can do yeah so
basically when we returned this new
score right yeah so we're gonna augment
these none just has to basically all be
the same format even though these
wouldn't actually produce a column value
none zero okay so we don't know which
column produces those and basically what
we need to do now is if we want to just
the score we need to get the first index
you need to get the first index here is
that it I think that might be it
and then I guess right here - this would
just give us a score so in this case -
we need to do none to common score
positions so basically we're always
because this is a recursive function we
always needed to return the same format
so we're now just saying you've returned
us the best score in the column that
produces the best score cool I think
this is it we can delete this pass so
let's go ahead and real quick test out
our you know our first attempt at the
minimax and to do that we can just go
down to here and - the best pick best
move what we're gonna do is do column
equals minimax of 0 all right so you
learn i think it's board then it is
depth so let's just for sake of
simplicity we'll start with depth equals
2 and then we are the maximizing player
so that isn't true
let's see if this works
nope damn it is validation where do we
get the error where do we get this error
too many indices for array 267 if is
valid location shoot let's see oh
alright yeah sorry I was just trying to
get the column out of here but we
actually get the column and the minimax
score so I kind of have to unpack the
tuple now it's not just one thing it
returns okay all right so what we should
see now think at depth of 2 it should be
smart enough to block
I guess not yet I was hoping that it
would block me from getting this
situation where I could win on either
side I'm gonna try increasing the depth
to 3 and see if it does that right so
what I'm trying to see is if it's
looking ahead in the future and how we
can tell that is just looking ahead in
the future it should prevent us from
getting wins that can we can kind of
have two spots where we win so if I drop
it here it needs to block me so that I
can't get the horizontal three on the
bottom still is not doing it what the
heck
might be some sort of error I wouldn't
just try one more time maybe seeing if
it's not looking far enough in the
future and do this depth for so this is
how far of a branch it's checking yeah
it's definitely having some issues here
it did win that time but it's always
picking zero it's always picking the
farthest to the left move why is that
the reason it is always picking the
farthest to the left even at depth of
four is let's go up and just check back
why is my mouth being so fidgety today
won't screw up for me is okay I see it
if we look at where we are returning
this column and value it is inside of
the for loop so it's on the first column
basically and also we initialize the
value to negative infinity so it's
basically okay it's figuring out that
whatever score is on the farthest to the
left column it's gonna be bigger than
negative infinity so it's setting that
comb here and then returning it
immediately but we need to do is just
backspace this once and hopefully now it
should be pretty good and I probably
need to go depth of for thinking about a
go to like depth of three and it will
still block just fine okay I kind of
want to go first just because I feel
like I'll see it easier okay so now it
needs to block one of my horizontals
which it does now which is good it needs
a block cool that's looking good okay
let's see if it's looking into the
future it should put its piece right
here next if I put it up here cool it's
looking good it's like smart enough to
know that like this position right here
where my mouse is was the best spot to
put it because that gives us a win here
and here so if it looks in the future
and knows it's going to win it's not
going to be easily blocked by me
looking good cool
all right real quick just because I'm
not positive how I feel about the values
that I currently set all these things up
here in the score positions function -
or I guess evaluate window I'm going to
just change these to what I sent when I
was playing around with this so the
window count equals 4 this actually is
pretty irrelevant at this point I think
the only reason this would play in is if
we set the depth equal to zero and it
had to use just this evaluate window so
I'm going to leave this in here but this
know that this is probably not too
important anymore I'll still keep this
value 100 okay three and one's a three
in a row I'm gonna give this a weight of
five tuner oh I'm gonna give this a
weight of two and remember that it's in
multiple direction so you could have
multiple twos in a row and it adds up
opponent equalling three and one this is
not as important anymore
because and also I have to kind of make
this a smaller value because is this is
factored into the terminal condition
case so it will look ahead in the future
and make sure that it's not losing so
I'm gonna make that I minus four then
the other thing that I changed to is
instead of making this times six I'm
gonna make the center column worth plus
three and these are values you should
play around with so if you really want
an expert the way I play around with
these values but honestly I feel like
this air right now like I'm gonna just
play a game like try to win I guess it's
still not amazing I guess its depth
three right now but yeah like look it
like it's making pretty good moves and
it's like gonna know to win if I put it
there I think this is a pretty good hey
I at this point to make it even better
what we can do is increase the depth of
how far it's looking where is that so if
you make it four it's looking if we
think about how the minimax works it's
looking farther down in this tree so
this four would represent how far it's
looking down it's like right now we're
at depth force that's why it's looking
this far down and you can think of this
graph as being all the possible ways a
connect four board can work so depth or
let's see this would be even better of
an AI because it's looking farther in
the future we could even make this
better let's just go to depth five and
see what happens okay
and kind of have a problem I don't if
you notice it but I did depth five and
it seems like it's just oh and finally
made a move it just takes forever to
make a move at this point try to like
think about why that is
you can even pause the video if you're
trying to like think about why that is
but yeah I mean if we're going if we're
doing depth 5 and we think about what
the minimax is doing it is branching out
at every step so the top of my hands is
the terminal node every time we do a
higher - oh my god I'm trying to be even
every time we do a higher depth we
expand exponentially more branches so
this is basically like 7 to the fifth
power
or maybe even six power because we also
look at 0 so it is a lot of branches to
expand so it's gonna run slowly so 5 is
probably the max you can really do
otherwise if you go to 6 your computer's
just going to explode not really but
basically it's probably gonna freeze up
and crash on you if you go to 6 so this
gets us to the final thing I'm going to
cover in the video and that is the alpha
beta pruning so it's basically allowing
us to go to deeper depth by eliminating
a lot of the moves we have to
look at and I didn't actually cover this
in the video I posted about how does a
boardgame AI work so check out a video I
posted in the description on kind of the
overview of it at a very high level yeah
basically it is figuring out that there
are certain branches that a computer is
just or an AI is just not likely to take
if it realizes like you know move if it
goes a certain position that it loses
it's not going to go down that branch so
you can just not look further down into
the future there yeah so check out that
video real quick on alpha beta pruning
and then once you've watched the video
we will implement alpha beta pruning to
allow us to more quickly search the
depths we want okay
alpha beta pruning so just like when we
are doing the minimax what I recommend
is look going to the alpha beta pruning
Wikipedia page and there's also
pseudocode there so I think that's
helpful the pseudocode is helpful to
follow but it's just basically an
adaptation of what we've already seen
with the minimax but now we have these
two additional parameters alpha and beta
and you should understand what these are
now that you've hopefully watch the
video I already had some knowledge about
how it worked so we're gonna go up to
our sorry I'm have this on another
screen because I don't want to screw
this step up you should go to your
minimax function and we're gonna be
adding our alpha and our beta to that
function and so we're also going to have
to pass this in to all of our other
calls of it alpha beta and right here
alpha beta and we'll also have to do it
down here when we actually call this and
if we remember the alpha and beta should
be initialized to negative math infinity
and this is just I'm looking at right
yeah the initial call right here
negative infinity negative bath infinity
math and infinity and true so that's the
initial call and then all right so let's
define this new minimax ocean without
the beta this should be a common here
all right so let's see what it's doing
so basically all we're doing is that in
addition to getting our max value we
also are just evaluating the alpha so we
can do this below the new score stuff so
alpha equals max of the new score or I
guess the value at this point we can do
value because it would have changed
value and alpha and then which we want
to do is or I'll just do it in the same
format that Wikipedia is doing so alpha
and the value okay and then what we want
to do is if alpha is greater than or
equal to beta then we want to break out
of our loop and that is good and then
same thing down here now we are the
minimizing player so we want to do beta
equals the min of the beta and the value
and if we find that alpha is greater
than or equal to beta then we have
recent condition where we're going to
just break off because we don't need to
look any more further in the tree and
we'll break so I think that's all we
need to do to implement alpha beta it's
pretty straightforward after you have
the minimax
up and so let's run this real quick I'll
probably get an error will say shoot I
need to not use my trackpad cuz
keep accidentally dropping pieces okay
it has peace there this should drop
quickly if before depth I was taking a
while now that we did this it should
drop quickly which was pretty good it's
pretty good reasonable more reasonable
than it was before for sure so I think
that is looking pretty good
and what we can honestly even do is now
that we're searching so far what we can
do is we have that initial time delay I
can actually just comment that out at
this point so this should be pretty
quick and we're going at depth five
which is pretty far down yeah that's not
bad I think even if we go to depth six
it's not too bad either but like before
if we went to def six it would take
forever
we'll see it also depends on what type
of processing power you have so I'm
going to try deficit here it's taken a
bit for sure did I do this right it but
not nearly as long as it was taking
before
yeah the alpha-beta pruning looks good
and one thing I just realized is that
you're gonna see more performance keynes
kind of as the game goes on further
because there's going to be at the start
of the game there's more possibilities
and less places that can break out of
that alpha beta thing but as a game goes
kind of on you'll have more breaks
frequently so the performance gains will
be definitely seen as the game continues
on all right
that's where we're going to end what I
would say too is like we have a pretty
dang good AI as is but I didn't there
are additional things we could do to
make it even better so a couple ideas
that I'm thinking about is one thing is
that currently it doesn't wait lower
like so if you think of the game we're
gonna run it real quick if you think of
these rows down at the bottom like this
first row here the second row etcetera
it should we should wait we should wait
what am i translating we should wait the
lower wins so like when you have three
in a row that's lower that probably be
weighted higher than if you have a three
in a row that's at the top here and
that's because you know as the game
fills up people have to put them on the
lower rows before the upper rows so like
if you are strategically playing as an
AI you would want to like put your
pieces down lower so you get more
chances to win also what I recommend is
you can make it even better than that by
watching the even-odd Connect for
strategy that I posted that's like a
really cool strategy that you could try
to implement with the AI you can also
let me think and there's other things
you could play around with off the head
I'm kind of spacing right now but the
values all can be tuned of the scores is
but yeah just have fun with it have fun
thank you guys for watching and peace
out
[Music]